[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم سلمى الجمل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع واحدا
وتتفاعلوا اخرى هذه الصور المباشره من
واشنطن التي مازلت تصدر منها المواقف
المتتابعه بعد الزياره التي قام بها
الرئيس الاوكراني اليها وخطوبه
وهذه الصور من المغرب قبل قليل ومن مدينه
المحمديه على وجه التحديد حيث شهدت
المدينه انفجارا كبيرا اثرا ذراعي حريق في
مخزن للغاز
وفي مواضع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
حرب اوكرانيا واصداء زياره الاولى لواشنطن
بعد الاعلان الامريكي عن تقديم منظومه
باتريوس ضمن حزمه مساعدات جديده بوتن يتم
واشنطن بالمشاركه في النزاع العسكري
ويتعهد بتدمير المنظومه فور وصولها رغم
تقليله من اهميتها العسكريه
وفي سياقه الدبلوماسيه استعداد روسي
لانهاء الحرب والتفاوض وتشكيكن امريكي
[تصفيق]
وعلى الارض القوات الاوكرانيه تؤكد
للجزيره السعاده السيطره على بخمت في
دنياز
[تصفيق]
وفي اعلان المضاد القوات الروسيه تقول
انها تواصل التقدم بالمقاطعه ذاتها
بالتزامني مع زياره لوزير الدفاع الى
منطقه العمليات العسكريه وواشنطن تقول ان
الاله العسكريه الروسيه في ماء وانا
مجموعه باتت بديلا لصعوبه تجنيد الروس
شرق اسيا واتساع رقعه التوتر تايوان تقول
انها ابعدت عشرات الطائرات الصينيه عن
مجالها الدفاعي مانيلا تتهم بجين بممارسه
انشطه في مياه متنازع عليها وترد بتعزيز
وجودها العسكري وفي تعقيبا على مناورات
مشتركه بينها وبين الصين موسكو تقول انها
رد فعل على ما سمته موقفه واشنطن
العدوانيه المتراكمه في المنطقه
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اعلان بنيامين نتنياهو
ليله الماضيه التوصل على الاتفاق مع شركاء
الجدد بتسل ايلس موترتش قبل دقائق من
انتهاء المهوله الممنوحه له لتشكيل
الحكومه هذه الشركه وصفت بالاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ الحكومات الاسرائيليه لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال الثاني ما هي فرص وبقائي
واستمرار التحالف الحكوميه الاسرائيليه
الجديد وجاءت النتيجه كما يلي نحو 22%
قالوا ان تحالف سيتمكن من اكمال لفتته في
حين رجعها نحو الثمانيه وسبعين في المئه
ان التحالف لن يستمر طويلا وسينفرط عقده
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصوير عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار 4 الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وانا نتطرق خلانه لقضايا مستجدات ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
تتابعونا في الحصاد ايضا
في لبنان وعلى واقع ازمه اقتصاديه متفاقمه
اكثر من 40000 طفل سوريا لاجئا خارج اسوار
المدارس
[موسيقى]
يعود رئيس الاوكراني بلو ديرمرزلنسكي من
واشنطن اولى زيارته الخارجيه الاولى منذ
بدا الحرب عوده حملت بمزيد من التعهد بدعم
امريكيا لا محدود وبمنظومه باتريوت زادت
مساحه السجال بين واشنطن و موسكو امريكيا
اشارت الى انهاء عسكريا روسيا وتشكيكا
برغبه موسكو في انهاء الحرب روسيا تعاهد
لبوتن بتدمير منظومه
استقبل الرئيس الاوكراني
بزيه العسكري في واشنطن استقبال الابطال
ويبدو ان ما حصل خلال هذه الزياره التي
بدات سريه وانتهت باستقبال تاريخيا في
الكونجرس ازعج موسكو كثيرا
الرئيس قال ان الولايات المتحده منخرطه في
تاجيج الاوضاع في دول الاتحاد السوفيتي
السابقه منذ مده طويله واشار في نفس الوقت
الى ان كل النزاعات المسلحه تنتهي
بالتفاوض وان هدف روسيا ليس اطاله امد
الصراع العسكري وانما انهائه وكل ما كان
ذلك اسرع كان افضل
وبخصوص الصواريخ باتريوت قال بوتين بتهكم
انها صواريخ قديمه لا تعمل مثل صواريخ اس
300 الروسيه وان روسيا ستاخذ ذلك بعين
الاعتبار وستجد وسيله لابطال مفعولها
واضاف ان القوات الروسيه ستدمر هذه
الصواريخ اذا نقلت الى اوكرانيا يعلق
الرئيس الروسي على اعلان الاداره
الامريكيه خلال زياده
و800 مليون دولار تشمل اسلحه دقيقه اخرى
وفيما يبدوك تقييم لهذه الزياره انه بكل
اسف للرئيس بايضا ولا الرئيس
روسيا واضاف ان هذا يدل على ان الولايات
المتحده تواصل حربها غير المباشره مع
روسيا حتى اخر اوكرانيا
اما في الولايات المتحده فقد رد منسقوا
الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكي جون كيربي على تصريحات
المسؤولين الروس بالقول انه لا يحق لاحد
اي جمله على الولايات المتحده نوعيه
المساعدات الامنيه التي تقدمها لاوكرانيا
واضاف ان واشنطن تركز الان على تزويد
اوكرانيا بمعدات الدفاع الجوي بسبب الشتاء
وبسبب تغيير بوتن تكتيكه العسكري وكشف
كربي عن ان الرئيسينكي بحث فكره السلام
العادل كمبدا لانهاء الحرب يبدو ان رئيس
الانسكي حقق المبتغى من زيارته واختار
توقيتها بعنايه فهي تاتي في بدايه فصل
الشتاء وفي وقت تشهد فيه المعارك على
الارض منعطف مهما كما تاتي قبيله تسلل من
جمهوريين رئاسه مجلس النواب الامريكي مع
العلم ان عدد من قادتهم يبدون تحفظا بشان
المساعدات الكبيره التي تقدمها واشنطن
لكيف وبعدهم قال انه لن يسلم شكرا يا شيكا
على بياض
اكد رئيس الروسي في بلادي في تصريحاته
اليوم ان روسيا تريد انهاء الحرب وانها
مستعده للتفاوض ولكن القياده الاوكرانيه
هي من منعت نفسها من التفاوض حسب قوله
[موسيقى]
هدفنا ليس الاستمرار في دفع عجله الصراع
العسكري بل على العكس هدفنا انهاء هذه
الحرب نحن نسعى لتحقيق ذلك وسنواصل العمل
وسنسع جاهدين لضمان اكتمال ذلك وكل ما كان
عاجلا كان افضل فيما يتعلق بما يحدث في
منطقه العمليه العسكريه وكيف لقد قلت مرات
عديده يؤدي تكثيف الاعمال العسكريه الى
خزائر غير مبرره ونعرف ان جميع النزاعات
المسلحه تنتهي بطريقه او باخرى بالمفاوضات
او على المصاري دبلوماسيه ولم نرفض
التفاوض فقط وانما القياده الاوكرانيه هي
منعت نفسها من التفاوض
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه فقال ان
بلاده تعمل مع حلفائها من اجل اصلاح
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا بعض
الاضرار التي لحقت بها جراء الحرب واضافها
بلانكن في مؤتمر صحفي نواف واشنطن تواصل
الوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا مهما تطلب الامر
وفقه تعبيره
ممكن تيجي
اخرين لاصلاح
اوكرانيا وحمايتها عبر انظمه دقيقه مثل
بطاريه صواريخ باتريوس التي اعلنها الرئيس
نحن مع اوكرانيا مهما تطلب الامر هذه هي
الرساله التي وجهها الرئيس بيض شخصيا خلال
استضافته في البيت الابيض وهو التزام
يدعمه
لان الرئيس بوتين
اهتمامه باي دبلوماسيه هادفه
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الجنرال ديفيد
بترايس المدير السابق لوكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه سنه ترايس مرحبا بك
معنا
بالرغم من السلبيه التي يظهر بها حديث
التسويه ان كان في تصريحات
10 في الوقت الذي لا زالت المزيد من
الدفعات
باتجاه
الاله العسكريه من قبل واشنطن لكيف خاصه
منظومه باتريوت برايك كيف يفهم هذا السياق
اعتقد ان اهم عنصر هنا هو التسريع اليوم
الذي يعتبر بوتين حرب اوكرانيا لم تعد
قائمه او ممكن على صحه معركه قصائد كثيره
التي يتعرضون لها الكثير من الخسائر كبيره
فقط الاشهر الاولى
عشر سنوات من هذه الخسائر فيها افغانستان
ليس في اي موقع يسمح له يطلع
مفاوضات مع بوتين الذي يبدو ما زال مصمم
على مطالبه الكبيره ولكن الشخص اللي بدا
هذه الحرب باطلاق حرب لا مبرر لها غزوه
لهم لبلده اذا الولايات المتحده
وافقت على واحد فاصل ثمانيه بالياردو نار
واليوم ايضا كان متاكد سمعته من مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي اصدر قائمه نفقات تشفر 45
مليار دولار كمساعدات انه اقتصاديه وامنيه
لاوكرانيا وهذا من شانه ان
يؤدي الى ما يحتاجونها الليله نهايه عام
2023 اذا فان موقف روسيا ضعيف جدا وهم لم
يحقق مهارات خاصه
الامريكي كبير جدا وهو محظه بقبول الحزبين
كما ظهر في تصويت مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس
النواب الذين اصدروا هذا القانون بالنظر
الغالبيه الموجوده
الحرب اذا لماذا لا زال هذا الدعم
الامريكي بهذا السخاء ان كان على صعيد
الدعم العسكري او حتى على صعيد الدعم
الاقتصادي همم ما الداعي لذلك اذا
اهميه
سبب ضروره تقديمها المساعد ليس من قبل
الولايات المتحده فقط من خلفائنا الشركاء
الغربيين في العالم كله هو ان روسيا تقوم
بمعاقبه اوكرانيا تدمر بناها تحتيه من
مجالات المائي والكهرباء
والتدفئه والماء في هذا الشتاء القاسي وكل
ذلك طبعا
الهجوم على المدنيين والمنى التحتيه
المدنيه وهذا يتطلب المساعدات كبيره جدا
الغربيه
العسكريه كبيره جدا وتعاود اعاده تجميعها
وتقويك قواتها ونحن سنحاوله تحسين القوات
الاوكرانيه بشكل الذين عبروا قواتهم بشكل
كبير ضد روسيا عليهم تذكر هذه حرب حرب
استقلال بالنسبه لهم يحاربون من اجل
البقاء على قيد على قيد الحياه
وبالتالي هم عازمنا على استماره
الامريكي وايضا
تفضل
عملت
كل الحكومات الاوكرانيه
همم في همم هذا الحديث اللي الذي تتحدث
عنه همم بخصوص تزويد همم الجانب الاوكراني
بمنظومه ما هو الفرق العسكري الذي تعول
عليه واشنطن في تقديمها منظومه للطرف
الاوكراني في هذا الوقت بعد 300 يوم من
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
منظومه
قبل كل شيء دفاعيه تماما ليس بهجوميه ولن
تطلقت صواريخ على روسيا بل هي فقط ستسمح
للقوات الاوكرانيه بدفاع عن نفسها بشكل
افضل ضد الصواريخ البالستيه الرهيبه التي
تطلقها روسيا على البنى التحتيه
الاوكرانيه في محاوله تدمير كل المده اللي
تحتيه المدنيه وليس اهداف عسكريه وايضا
تستخدم المسيارات الايرانيه لذلك
كما انهم يحاولون التقديم وسائل الدفاع ضد
الصواريخ بالستيه الروسيه وهذا ما ستفعله
سيكون هناك ثمانيه اطلاقات واربعه همم
ضد مسيرات بسيطه فقط ضد الصواريخ
البالستيه
كبيره خطيره التي تستخدم على تدمير البناء
التحتيه في على البنيه التحتيه والكاميرون
الكهربائي انه ما فيه اوكرانيا
والرئيس الاوكراني زيلينسكي جرى التطرق
الى مبدا السلام العادل ما هي مواصفات
السلام العادل من وجهه النظر
الاوكرانيه الامريكيه
فهذا هو مصطلح الاستخدمه السلام العادل
اعتقد من مفهوم انه هو انسحاب روسيا من كل
الاراضي الاقرانيه التي تحتلها
وتسديد تعويض عن الضرر لاخصابه
شكرا لك من واشنطن الجن المدير السابق
لوكاله الاستخبارات المركزيه الامريكيه
وارحب بضيفي من موسكو سيد مدريد
سيد بابك
الدفع الامريكي بالمزيد من الدعم باتجاه
العسكر الاخرانيه ياتي في ظل التقدم
اوكراني وفي ظل انتصارات اوكرانيه حسب
الجانب الامريكي وياتي ايضا لتسريع فهم
الرئيس بوتين بان همم كسب هذا هذه الحرب
امر غير ممكن والخسائر هي اكبر شاهد على
ذلك برايك هل هذا الامر
يبعد
الذهاب الى تسويه بين الطرفين
اوعي تنكر
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا
بكلفه عشرات ملايين الدولارات فهذا طبعا
مده الحرب ويجعل السلامه اكثر صعوبه ولكن
في نهايه المطاف بالتاكيد روسيا سوف تقبل
لانه
ببساطهم ووضع نفسهم هدفا لا يمكن تحقيقه
قبل الثمان سنوات فقط قرروا انه الغاء اي
اثر اللي 400 سنه من التاريخ فالشرق
اوكرانيا لطالما كانت تحت روسيا لو ضمن
روسيا منذ منتصف القرن السادس قبل ان حتى
تتحقق او تظهر للوجود دوله من اسمها
الولايات المتحده اذا هو يحاولون محو
التاريخ هذا الحكومه القوميه الحاليه في
اوكرانيا كما ان هناك بعض الحقائق التي
همم
لزيت باتريس باتريس اعترف بها قبل ان تبدا
روسيا بتدمير البناء التحتيه والكهرباء
وما ذلك في اوكرانيا حاول روسيا حاولت
تدميره جسر شبه الجزيره
من الكهرباء
لمده ثمان سنوات
اراضي مساحه لبنان ولكن هناك ممر من روسيا
الى شبه جزيره الخرمه وهذا هذا العمار
عريض جدا ومحم جيدا وهو انجاص كبير وهو
يمثل كما قلته مساحه سوريا
وطبعا ان الحرب قد تتغير مسارها في
المستقبل لكن روسيا مصممه على الانتصار
الحرب
الروسيه ما الذي سيغير هذه النظره
لكليهما بعد مرور ثلاث مئه يوم او اكثر
على هذه الحرب
جيلنسكي
الروس وقد اوقف المفاوضات لان النظامه
ليست ديمقراطيا ولا يعكس رغبات الشعب انا
متاكد ان اوكرانيا تريد السلام او الشعب
الاوكراني يريد السلام مع روسيا هو في
روسيا هناك الكثير الانتقادات حول طريقه
لانه من الواضح ان روسيا حاولت ان تسيطر
على اوكرانيا بقوات غير كافيه فقط فقط
لبلد سكانها 40 مليون شخص وبالتالي يمكن
الانتقاد ذلك في روس يمكن
كل كل الانتقادات
غادر البلاد اما في اوكرانيا لا يمكن لاي
شخص ان يغادر بلاده الا اذا كانوا اطفال
او اشخاص مسنين اذا اكلته مجره بلد او
نظام دكتاتوري اكثر من روسيا وبالتالي
يمكن يخاطر بحياه ابناء الشعبهم ويرفضن
التفوق او ان اذكركم ليست روسيا التي توقف
المفاوضات في نهايه الشهر
فريق التاريخ
ما ينفعش اي مكان
[موسيقى]
على الارض قال ناطق باسم قياده الجيش
الاوكراني السرجيه شيريفاتي ان الجيش
استعاده السيطره بشكل كامل على مدينه
باخمود واضاف في تصريح للجزيره ان المدينه
تتعرضوا لقصف مكثفا بالصواريخ بعد اخراج
القوات الروسيه هذا وقالت هيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيا ان قواتها صدات هجمات الروسيه
على مواقعها في المدينه ونجاحات في طرد
القوات الروسيه وقواتنا الخارجه حدود
المنطقه الصناعيه
محمود كانت محور القتال لاشهر بين الطرفين
اتعرف على اهميتها في تقرير التالي
لكن ما هي اهميه هذه المدينه التي حاولت
روسيا سيطره عليها منذ بدايه الحرب تقع
باخمد على ضفتين نهري
شماليه مقاطعه يونيفرس في اقليم جمباز
شرقيه اوكرانيا وتبعد نحو 600 كيلو متر عن
العاصمه كيف تعد ضخمه
للدفاع عن مدن منطقه فمنها توجه ضربات
للمواقع الروسيه بما في ذلك مدينه دنيتك
عاصمه المقاطعه وهي هامه الروس بعد
خسارتهم مدينه ازون جنوب منطقه خفيف في
شهر سبتمبر اصبحت البوابه الجنوبيه
الشرقيه شبه الوحيده لتقدم لقوات الروسيه
في عمق منطقه اليونيسكو اضافه الى كونها
عقده مواصلات هامه يمر فيها خط حديدي يربط
جنوب وشرق حوض دنياك بالغرب والشمال
الاوكرانيه اخيرا تشكر باخمته واحده من
اكبر مراكز الاله الثقيله في اوكرانيا كما
انها تساهم بنحو 30 في المئه من الملح
الصخري في البلاد
وفعلا المضاد قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
ان قواتها تواصل التقدمات في محور دوناتس
وانها قضت على نحو 50 عسكريا اوكرانيا من
جهه قالت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه ان رئيس
حكومه دونيت الماليه لروسيا والرئيس
السابق لوكاله الفضاء الروسيه اصيب في قصف
الاوكراني استهدف جنوبيه
لوزير الدفاع الروسيه الى مواقع القوات
الروسيه في منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه
باوكرانيا والتقى بالجنود والضباط وتفقد
اماكن وجودهم على الخطوط الاماميه للجبهه
وتعتبر الزياره الثانيه من نوعها لمنطقه
العمليات العسكريه في غضون اسبوع
في واشنطن قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطونيو بلينكن ان الاله العسكريه الروسيه
باتت في مازقنا الان وكان منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي جون كيربي قال ان بوتين لجا الى
شركه فاجنر بسبب الصعوبه في تجنيد الروسي
للقتال في اوكرانيا واضاف كيربي في احاطه
له ان شركه فاجنر تعاني من خسائر بشريه
فادحه وفقدت الاسبوع الماضي نحو الفن من
مقاتلها انها اشترت اسلحه من كوريا
الشماليه لتعزيز مقاتلها في اوكرانيا
عقابيه جديده ضد فاجنر
ضموا الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد الياس
ما الذي يجري في باخموت بين تاكيد
الاوكراني بالصيطره عليها
والروايه اخرى مضاده روسيه
كر وفر حول بخموط
محاور الهجوم هي من شمال وجنوب محمود وحتى
من الشرق ولكن اليوم كمدينه بحد ذاتها لم
تسقط وهذا امر يعني تظهره الدلائل
التكتيكيه على الارض هذه المدينه مهمه
قبل ان كانت مهمه اليوم اقل اهميه يعني
عندما نتحدث عن سفيردونالدز شانس كانتين
مدينتين سقطت محمود كانت الخلفيه
اللوجستيه اليوم بخموت هي المدخل الى
كرامه تورسك ولكن تراجعت اهميتها بعد سقوط
الزيون لكنها معركه شخصيه وخاصه لممول
شركه
لانه يريد اثبات ان هناك
هي اكثر من الجيش الروسي وهو يطالب ان
ياخذ يعني ترتيب معين وشرعيه معينه من
حكومه الروسيه وخاصه من الرئيس بوتين خاصه
اذا تحقق هذا الامر بالاضافه سلمى الى همم
خلسون التعويض في محمود فقط لموضوع
المعنويات وموضوع عدم التراجع
همم شركه فاجنر الى اي درجه همم ترى همم
المقاربه العمليه
لهذه الشركه هي مقاربه همم عسكريه مجديه
على الارض في ظل حديث امريكي ايضا عن
ضروره استهدافها في العقوبه
يعني العقوبات شيء معين قد يكون تاثيرها
اقل لانها رمزيه قد تكون لان التمويل ياتي
من الداخل والسلاح كما قلت في التقرير
ياتي من كوريا الشماليه هذه ال ال ال ال
الشركه بالقانون الروسي ليست موجوده لا
يعترف فيها لها عمليات متعدده خارج حتى
روسيه من سوريا الى غرب افريقيا هي شيء
مهم لانها تقاتل بطريقه مختلفه ولكن اليوم
هذا الاستثمار الكبير في مخموت هو كبير
جدا مقابل الارباح التي قد تاتي انها تثبت
الكثير من العسكر همم الروسي بدل ان يكون
في جبهه اخرى مختلفه ههه شكرا لك عميد
الياس حنا حدثتنا من بيروت
[موسيقى]
تتواصلوا المناورات العسكريه الصينيه
الروسيه في بحر الصين الشرقيه
ولم تخفي موسكو على لسان رئيس الاركان
الروسيه ان هذه التدريبات هي رد على
النشاط العدواني الامريكيه المتراكمه في
المنطقه
جيشها بتعزيز وجوده العسكري في بحر جنوب
الصين
في مياه متنازع عليها وفق ما ورد في بيان
وزاره الدفاع الفلبينيه
عميقه الخلافات بين الصين وبعض جيرانها
وامواجها عاتيه اكثر هذه الايام كل تقارب
بين بيتين وموسكو يزيد الهوت والتوتر في
المنطقه بعيون غير راضيه
دول الجوار المنوره الصينيه الروسيه في
بحر الصين الشرقي على سطح مياه المنطقه
تطفو ازمه قديمه جديده بشان ممرات مائيه
وجزر متنازع عليها ستدوم المناوره اسبوعا
وليست عاديه من حيث التوقيت والاهداف اصرت
موسكو على التوضيح وفق رئيسي اركان الجيش
الروسي
هذا التعاون رد فعل طبيعي على التراكم
العدواني للامكانات العسكريه الامريكيه في
المنطقه مضيفا ان هدف التدريبات المشتركه
هو زياده قدره الجيشين على مقاومه
التحديات والتهديدات الجديده
مستنفره وتشعر بالتهديد مما يجري بالقرب
منها اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الطائرات الحربيه
الصينيه بتنفيذ استعراض للقوه فوق مضيق
تايوان خلال الساعات الاربع والعشرين
الماضيه اضاف البيان ان 39 طائره حربيه
حلقت في اجواء جنوب غربي الجزيره بالاضافه
الى ثلاث سفن حربيه عبرت وسط مضيق تايوان
دخلت الفيليبين ايضا على خط المنزعجين من
تحركات التلميذ النائم اذ امرت مانيلا
جيشها بتعزيز وجوده في بحر الصين الجنوبي
السبب وفقها التهديد الذي تواجهه حاميه في
الممر المائي المتنازع عليه بسبب انشطه
صينيه غريبه ياتي هذا التطور بعد يومين
فقط من تقارير اعلاميه تحدثت عن السعاده
بيجين المزيد من الاراضي في ارخبيل
سبارتلي بدا النصين تلك الضرير وايضا
روايه مانيلا بشان استعاده حطام صاروخ
صيني لسفينه تابعه للبحريه الفلبينيه قبله
جزيره فيو كان حلف المتوجهين من الخطر
الصيني في المنطقه سنابا لخلافات قديمه
وتقارير غربيه كثيره منذ حرب اوكرانيا
يتوسع اكثر هذه الاونه قرروا طوكيو
التاريخ قبل ايام بتغيير سياستها الدفاعيه
جزء من هذا التحالف الذي لا ينضوي
بالضروره تحت سن واحد او مظله رسميه لم
تخفي الحكومه اليابانيه ان المراجعه
الجذريه هي محاوله للتصدي للنفذ العسكريه
الصيني والمواجهه تحدي نستراتيجي غير
مسبوق لامن الارخبيل ترياسه موسكو حليفه
بضعه ايام قبل ان تدين مساماتها عسكرت
اليابان وجاء في بيان الخارجيه الروسيه ان
مثل هذا التحرك سيثير حتما تحديات امنيه
ايه ده وسيؤدي الى تصعيد التوتر في منطقتي
اسيا والمحيط الهادي له دوء على المديين
القريب والمتوسط بين معسكر الصين روسيا
ومعسكر كل من يستشعر التهديد منهما او
احداهما ويميل اكثر للحلف الغربي بقياده
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما بعد بعد
الحرب في اوكرانيا لحدود له
نائب رئيس مركز الصين ولا عولمه ومن
واشنطن دكتور ريتشارد وايت رئيس قسم
دراسات الصين مرحبا بكما سيد جو ما هي
الاهداف من وراء هذه المناورات الاهداف
الصينيه بطبيعه الحال من وراء المناورات
مع طرف الروسي في هذه المنطقه المتوتره في
هذا التوقيت
الصين
وعلاقتها
1989 91 العلاقات بين روسيا والصين لما
كانت قويه وذات جذور عميقه من التعاون بين
البلدين والجيشين وان البلدين قام بقيام
مناورات المشتركه على الارض وعلى البحر
منذ سنوات طويله
من باب المستخدم
العسكري على كل الجبهات لذلك في هذه
الحاله بالذات اعتقد ان كل من
الصينما استعدادا لاي احتمال وجود مواجهه
تفرض على اي طرف في اي بلد من الاثنين ليس
في هذا الجزء العانه فقط على الصعيد
عالميه وان مثل هذا الكتاب بالصداقه
والعلاقات الاخويه
الوديه جيده بين البلدين تشاركونا اكثر
4000 كيلو متر من الاراضي المشتركه
والحدود مشتركه هو عنصر مهم جدا يساعد في
تحقيق السلام والاستقرار ليس فقط على
الصعيد
العالميين من التعاون في مثل هذه الفتره
كما وصفت روسيا بانها مناورات هي ليست
عاديه في هذا التوقيت تحديدا وستمر مده
اسبوع كيف تنظر اليها واشنطن
فيكتوريا
بان هذه واحده من سلسله مناورات تقوم بها
الصين وروسيا منذ سنوات عديده
وهما هذه
تحصل مرتين في السنه واحيانا تشارك فيها
مثلا جنوب افريقيا وايران في بعض المرات
الذي يقومون مناورات صغيره معها هذه
المناورات
ما يسوع اليها من قبل واشنطن على انها
مثيره للقلق لحد ما لكن ليس بشكل ليس الان
بل تعتبر انها مصممه لتحسين مهارات
الجيشين وارسال اشعارات الى واشنطن
واليابان بشكل خاص
لتسجيل بيع السلاح الروسي الصين
ربما ولكنها ليست
بحجم كبير واهميه كما هي المناورات لاجرت
الولايات المتحده مع الشركات
الجنوبيه ومع اليابان او التي قامت بها
روسيا مع بيروسيا على سبيل المثال
ارجع وهذه المناورات دفعت مجموعه الدول
المعنيه في تلك المنطقه اا بمثل هذا هذه
المناورات مثل هذا التصعيد في الاجواء
دفعتها الى المزيد من التوجس وبالتالي الى
المزيد من العسكر ومن الانشطه ايضا
العسكريه في تلك المنطقه ااه كيف تنظر
بجين الى هذا رد الفعل لهذه الدول
المتوجهه وفي مخاوفها المتزايده وفي ردود
فعلها الى درجه هي معنيه باحتواء مثل هذه
المخاوف
اولا لو كان هناك اي مخاوف كما ذكرت او
قلق فهذا غير الاساس له لانه في هذا جزء
من العالم دول مثل الولايات المتحده
واليابان وجمهوريه
كوريا واستراليا وغيرها تقوم دائما بشكل
الاعتيادي بمناورات سنويه ومرتين في السنه
من كل الالوان
شرق اسيا
نعم
انه ينبغي الجميع ان يتوقعوا ان الصين
وروسيا ملتزمان بالتعاون فيما بينهما حول
عده قطاعات من ذلك القطاع العسكري
والجيشان سيواصلون احترام بعضهم الاخر
والتعاون
خاصه
وتعلم كيفيه التنسيق بينهما مثلا في حالات
الاشارات
والمعلومات وايضا ان يكونوا مستعدين اذا
ما حصلت اي حاله طارئه
يكون عنصر ويسهل للسلام والاستقرار
الاقليمي وليس عقلي ذلك
بينهما في القطاع العسكري
لدى الدول المحيطه في همم في تلك في تلك
المنطقه منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
المعنيه بمثل هذا التوتر برفع مثلا
بميزانياتها العسكريه وايضا تصعيد اجرائي
مثلا لحضورها العسكري مثل الفلبين والى اي
درجه الولايات المتحده معنيه بدعمها
ان نضع هذه المناورات في سياقها الصحيح ما
هو يدعو للقلق بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
واليابان
والفلبين وغيرهم من الدول هو اساسا النمو
وزياده القوه العسكريه الصينيه
الشديده التي تتخذها الحكومه الصينيه حول
الخلافات والقضايا مثل موضوع ايوان وبحر
الجنوب الصين
العدوانيه الروسيه كما ظهرت في حرب
اوكرانيا اذا المناورات هي جزء من هذا
ولكن ذلك اوسع من امر زائد الصين وروسيا
يتحديان
النظام الاقليمي الحالي ويحاولان توسيعه
نفوذهما
انا اراضي متنازع عليها وهذا ما يثير
القلق وهو نمو وزياده
قاتين الدوله التين
المعاديتين لولايات المتحده وحلفاء
وشركائها
ما رايك بهذا الحديث سيد فاكتور جاو
وبالتالي من مستقبل العلاقات الصينيه مع
الولايات المتحده في هذه المتقود الجوار
في ما يتعلق بما قاله الضيف في الامريكي
المحترم قبل قليل فوق وتحدث
الولايات المتحده اعتقد ان العكس
ذلك في الولايات المتحده السياسه اداء اي
ضد الصيد مما يجبر الصينيه الصين اكثر
الدفاع عن عن
مصالحهم المشروعه اذا
العلماء بمسمىاتها ولا نغيرها والا سنه
ضحيه العدوان على ان هو الذي قام
بعدوان والاعتداء من وجهه نظر الصين الصين
سعيده جدا بان تعيش بسلام وتتوافق مع
الولايات المتحده ليس لدينا اي طموحات
المعاديه للولايات المتحده نحن بلد
لنا حق الدفاع عن نفسنا فيما يتعلق بحمايه
سياده هو مصالحها الاقليميه المشروعه
الصين لن تتخذ اي لا تاخذ اي قطعه ارض من
اي بلد لا تعود وشرعا الى الصين لكن الصين
لن تسمح لاي جندي اجنبي ان يضعف قدمه على
الارض الصينيه وهذا مثلا حقيقه سواء
بقدرته الخاصه
[موسيقى]
تسببت الازمه الاقتصاديه في لبنان في عدم
التحاق اكثر من 400 الف طفل سوريه لاجئ في
هذا البلد بالمدارس وفق منظمه اليونيسف
وحذرت منظمات المحليه ودوليه من خطوره
تشكل جيلا كاملا من الاطفال السوريين
الاميين ما يدفع هؤلاء الانخراط في سوق
العمل وحرمانهم من احد حقوقهم الاساسيه
التعليم
ليست مجرد ان نزهه عاديه لطفل يلهو على
دراجات الهوائيه بل هي رحله زكريا اليوميه
لالى مدرسته بل الى ورشه العمل
يتحمل اللاجئ السوري الذي لم يتجاوز عمره
13 ربيعا مشقه العمل ليجن الفتاه وعلى
يديه الصغيرتين حفرت ساعات العمل الطويله
ندوبا وتركت في قلبه غصه
من عمر تسعه سنين
وعملت عروس
سبعه للخمسه سته
يوميات من مقاس الوجوه
هؤلاء الاطفال السوريون وجدوا فرصه تعليم
منها الاف اخرون اما المدرسه التي تحتضنهم
ستقاوم تحديات الازمه وتواجه خطر اقفال
ابوابها امام مئات اللاجئين
همم
يوم الايام انه المدرسه تقفل الابوابها
ازابيه الازمه الاقتصاديه على ما هي عليه
يا هيمونا على وجوههم المنهكه طوال اليوم
حملتهم رياح الحرب الى بلاد يتارجح فيها
مستقبلهم بين السيء والاسوا
ذلك ان كثيرا منهم ارغم على ترك مقاعد
الدراسه بفعل الازمه الاقتصاديه في ما
ارتفعت نسبه الاميين بينهم وهو ما ينبئ
وفق المنظمات الدوليه بتشكل جيل الامي
كامل في صفوف اللاجئين السوريين
والمنحه بزياده الاستثمار
بنظام الدراسي لمنعه من انهيار لبنان
يوميا وتتخلص معها احلام جيل سوريه
من الازمات التي يشهدها لبنان بعد نجاته
من اكون الحرب في سوريا
يدفعوا الاطفال السوريون في لبنان ضريبه
اللجوء وما ينجم عنه من تبعات مريره
فهؤلاء حرموا منذ ولادتهم من ابسط حقوقهم
لا سيما التعليم ما دفع المنظمات الاهليه
للتحذير من مخاطر تشكل جيل الامين نتيجه
قصور السياسات عم دمجهم تربويه كارمن
الجزيره البقاع شرقيه لبنان
[موسيقى]
في مزيد من الاخبار طلبه 69 من نواب
المعارضه في البرلمان الفنزويلي انهاء عمل
الحكومه المؤقته التي يتراسها خوان
بان الحكومه ضاعفت بعد اربع سنوات من
اعلانها ولم تحقق اهدافها السياسيه وقال
النواب ان الدعم الدوليه الواسع الذي
يتمتع به اخوان وايدو في عام 2019 تراجع
وكان هؤلاء المعارضون ايدوا اعلان كودو
نفسه رئيسا مؤقتا في 2019 عندما كانت
المعارضه تسيطر على البرلمان هذه المطالبه
تاتي بعد اختراق حققته المفاوضات بين
السلطه الفازلين والمعارضه الشهر الماضي
وهو ما قبل بترحيب غربيه وامنيه ثم تبع
ذلك قرار امريكي بالسماحي لشركه نفسيه بس
انا في عملها هناك كجزء من تخفيف العقوبات
وهو ما اعتبره لبعض قرارا مدفعا بالحاجه
الامريكيه والغربيه
تعتبر وفنزويلا من اكبر الدول نفطيه في
العالم لكن مع معدلات الفقر مرتفعه
ومستويات لتنميه متدينه فنزويلا الواقعه
في جنوب القاره الامريكيه هي من مؤسسي
منظمات اوبك وتقدر احتياطاتها النفطيه
المؤكده باكثر من 300 مليار برميل اين نحو
ربع احتياطات اوفيك ظلت الولايات المتحده
اكبر مستوردا للخام الفنزويلي حتى اواخر
التسعينيات حيث تاثرت العلاقه سلبا بعد
فوز الاشتراك الراحل هوجن تشافيز في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه وعلى مدى سنوات
اللاحقه خضعت فنزويلا لعقوبات امريكيه ادت
مع الازمه السياسيه وتفشي الفساد الى تقلص
انتاج النفط يوميا من نحو ثلاثه ملايين
برميل الى حوالي نصف مليون برميل لكن منذ
العام الماضي اتخذ انتاج فنزويلا من النفط
الخام سعرا سعوديا حيث يتخطى سبع مئه الف
برميل يوميا في ابريل الماضي مدفوعا بتولي
الاداره ديمقرا الحكم في الولايات المتحده
ومع احتدام ازمه طاقه في العالم بسبب
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه خففت واشنطن في
نوفمبر الماضي عقوباتها على كراكاس وسمحت
لشركات شيفرون النفطيه باستئناف في عملها
اثرا نجاحي فرقاء الازمه السياسيه هناك في
ابرام اتفاق كما تمتلك فنزويلا ثاني اكبر
احتياطات مؤكده من الغاز الطبيعي في
الامريكيتين بعد الولايات المتحده باكثر
من سته تريليونات متر مكعب وذلك وفقا
لبيانات شركات بي بي البريطانيه ومجله
النفط والغاز الامريكي
بداوا الحلقه العقاد في العلاقات
الفنزويليه الامريكيه مؤخرا اتى بعد نحوي
عقدين من التوتر وانعدام الثقه بين
البلدين فاا في عام 2008 فنزويلا اداره
الرئيس الامريكي الاسباق جورج دبليو بوش
بدعم محاوله الانقلاب الفاشله ضد الرئيس
تشافيز وفي عام
2008 قطعت كاس العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع
واشنطن تضامنا مع بوليفيا التي ادرجها بوش
على قائمه سوداء لمكافحه المخدرات الى
جانب فنزويلا لكن العلاقات سرعانه مستؤلفت
في يونيو 2009 اثر تولي بارك اوباما
السلطه في الولايات المتحده وفي عام
2019 امهلت فنزويلا البحث الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه اثنتين وسبعين ساعتين لمغادره
البلاد ردا على قرار الرئيس دونالد ترامب
الاعتراف بزعيم المعارضه الفنزويليه اخوان
رئيسا مؤقتا للبلاد قال مزيد من الضوء حول
هذا الملف ينضم الينا من واشنطن السفير
مسعود معلوف الخبير في الشؤون
الامريكيتين سفير مسعود مرحبا بك معنا اذا
هل يمكن النظر الى ان السوق الطاقه سيكون
مفتاح الحالات العلاقات الفنزويليه
الامريكيه
اولا تحيه لك وتحيه للمشاهدين الكرام
لنبدا بالقول بان علاقات الولايات المتحده
مع فنزويلا ما زالت في وضع متازم جدا
الولايات المتحده ما زالت حتى الان تفرض
كثيرا من العقوبات على فنزويلا والولايات
المتحده حتى الان ما زالت تعترف باخوان
غويدو وكانه الرئيس المنتخب
لفنزويلا ولكن ولكن بسبب ازمه النفط
الناتجه عن الحرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وشح
النفط الواصل الى اوروبا والحاجه
الاوروبيه في بدايه فصل الشتاء هذا راى
الرئيس بيضا انه من الافضل ان يجد مصادر
اخرى للطاقه للغاز والبترول ل همم
لايصالها الى اوروبا للتخفيف قدر المستطاع
من هذه الازمه التي اصابت الدول الاوروبيه
ولكي يتجنب ايضا خروج بعض الدول الاوروبيه
عن تح فيها مع الولايات المتحده في حرب
روسيا ضد اوكرانيا من هذا المنطلق راينا
انه هنالك بعض التخفيف وكانه هنالك باب
صغير بدا ينفتح في العلاقات بين الولايات
المتحده
وفينزويلا والجدير بالاشاره اليه هنا هو
ان دول ما يعرف بمجموعهما وهي مجموعه من
دول امريكا الجنوبيه التي في عام 2019
تضامنت مع بعضها البعض خلافا ل همم رئيس
ما دوره وتقييدا للرئيس المنتخب انا ذاك
اخوان جويده ولكن هذا هذه المجموعه بدات
بدات تعود عدد من الدول تنسحب منها شيئا
فشيئا المكسيك وغيرها من كولومبيا مثلا
عادت فتح حدودها مع فنزويلا والرئيس
المنتخب في البرازيل لولاد سيلفا اعلن انه
بعد ان يستلم الرئاسه سوف
العلاقات مع فنزويلا من هذا المنطلق نرى
ان فنزويلا تعود في شيئا فشيئا الى كونها
دوله معترف بها دوليا بنظامها برئاسه
الرئيس عفوا الرئيس ما دوره وربما ربما
ستحسن شيئا فشيئا الولايات المتحده
علاقاتها مع لن يكون هنالك تغير جذري
مباشر ولكن ربما تدريجيا والحاجه الى
النفط المتزايده في العالم قد تؤدي الى
تخفيض بعض العقوبات بصوره تدريجيه من قبل
الولايات المتحده تجاه بني
فنزويلا الى سوق الطاقه الى اي درجه من
وجهه نظرك سيؤثر في اسواق الطاقه والحاجه
الامريكيه
للنفط في مرحله الحرب الروسيه الاخرانيه
سيكون له تاثير ليست قويا جدا لان
الانتاج الفنزويلي ليس بهذه الكميه الكبرى
ولكن وبن العقوبات ايضا مازالت قائمه على
الولايات المتحده ان ترفع اكثر واكثر من
العقوبات وذلك سيتطلب بعد الوقت سواء من
قبل الولايات المتحده او من قبل الانتاج
في داخل زانزويلا سيساعد بعض الشيء ولكنه
لن يحل المشكله لان اوروبا كانت تعتمد
بنسبه مرتفعه نسبه مئويه مرتفعه جدا من
حاجتها الى الطاقه كانت تعتمد على روسيا
وهذه الكميه انخفضت بشكل دراماتيكيا قويا
جدا ولا تستطيع فنزويلا وحدها ان تحل
روسيا وقد حاول الرئيس ايضا
سيد السعوديه
جزئيه لهذه العلاقه هل مدفوعه فقط بسوق
الطاقه اما ايضا عدم نجاح غوايدو التعويل
على جوايدو من قبل الولايات المتحده
نعم من الجهتين اليس فقط للولايات المتحده
بل ان ايضا المعارضه الداخليه في فنزويلا
لم تتمكن من حراز اي تقدم بالنسبه الى
رئاسه وعدد كبير من الدول ايضا التي كانت
قاطعه فنزويلا بسبب الانتخابات كويده بدات
تتراجع عن ذلك ولا تريد الولايات المتحده
ان تجد نفسها وحيده ربما فيها هذا الموقف
ومن جهه الثانيه هنالك الحاجه الى الطاقه
الحاجه الى الغاز والبترول في اوروبا لا
لذلك المتحده تنفتح شيئا وشيئا على شيئا
فشيئا على فنزويلا ولكن انا شخصيا لا
اعتقد انه سيكون تحول مباشره وكبير شكرا
لكم
[موسيقى]
بينما ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله نتوقف عند
الخبر والصوره التي كانت معناها قبل قليل
من لبنان وفيها كان الحديث مفصلا عن
معاناه المكثفه وممتده يعيشها اللاجئين
السوريين هذه المره كان عنوانها التعليم
ببقاء 400000 من اطفالهم في لبنان خارج
اسوار المدارس جيل كامل منهم سيكونوا بلا
تعليم سيكون عنوانا لمعاناه عابره للاجيال
مالا نتحرك جميعا
تصبحون على عالم افضل
[موسيقى]